officiellement je vous annonce que je
prends ma retraite a beaucoup d'émotion
hier lors de l'annoncé de sa retraite
ans le boxeur champion du monde qui a
décidé d'accrocher ses gants après 15
ans chez les professionnels le champ de
goûter qui nous fait l'honneur de venir
nous voir en studio ce matin bonjour lui
tiennent bon mois précise me taire
karimi ce matin à savoir ça va mieux
c'est oui c'est beaucoup d émotion
conditions difficiles mais encore une
fois je sors de ce sport là avec la tête
très haut très satisfait pour qu'est-ce
que jamais pour tout qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait qu'est ce que j'ai réalisé réaliser
ces magnifiques les moments que j'ai
passés ici elles sont inoubliables gris
gelé des plaines
très forte émotion le tchad avec raison
d'ailleurs on pourra jamais vous enlevez
les neuf défense de titre de champion du
monde ça c'est certain mais pourquoi
avoir attendu deux ans avant d'avoir
annoncé la retraite chic 7d peut-être se
passe en décembre dont il ya eu adonis
stevenson l'accident et tout mais
pourquoi avoir attendu deux ans c'était
pas en question que j'ai attendu deux
ans une question que j'ai réfléchi j'ai
pris mon temps comme il faut c'était une
semaine après mon dernier combat avec
alvarez ma fille est venue au monde une
petite fille emma j'ai profité j'ai
profité de passer plus de temps avec
avec elle puis comme je me répète comme
il faut oui je vous le répète j'ai
rester j'ai pensé comme il faut avant
que je prends des conditions cette
version 2 mais on voit que je les prie
je suis convaincu que il a pas de la
tôle pour moi ça change également et
exactement puis mon 12e y arriver entre
le temps
qui sait ça je veux être un père à santé
puis des passions des enfants d'aider ma
famille je vais rien à prouver
j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai fait
sur le ring du paiement 15 ans mais
aujourd'hui encore une fois je sors de
ce sport avec la tête très haut très
satisfait pour tout cas ce que j'ai
réalisé parlant des enfants voyaient
leur fille emma il ya eu un garçon
comment il s'appelle déjà s'appelle eric
stéphane pourquoi il restait pas avec
mon père c'est stéphane puis on a choisi
maps et ma foi ma femme on a choisi eric
juste comme ça
éric lucas stéphane larouche ça tombait
comme ça mais c'était pas si c'est à
cause d'eux à cause de ça c'était mon
père qui s'appelle stéphane que le tchad
où vous quittez après 15 ans à quoi vous
avez marqué la boxe au québec
vous croyez je sais pas c'était l'outil
en bouteille je t'aimerai toujours
jessains ajustée1 personnes honnêtes qui
travaillent beaucoup
je sais pas toutes ces qualités là ça
donnait que l'outil un goûter le monde y
attendait avec un amour avec avec lui
c'était ma personne ma sincérité et avec
raison tout le monde est exact il bon
gars
un bon boxeur évidemment naturel si
nature j'ai toujours comme ça j'ai
jamais j'ai des jupes à jamais était
fedex une autre personne c'était vrai à
100% à chaque fois et c'est quoi vos
projets pour la suite
écoute c'est ce que je me restait deux
minutes de sport mais c'est un que dans
une autre manière
peut-être que mon corps mon agent comme
promoteur pourquoi pas jouer à caumont
analyste de boxe avec mon expertise
depuis 25 ans je peux je peux les
enfants les gens qui est qui veut faire
du sport pour le programme mais pas
entraîneur ça ça vous intéresse pas du
tout c'est dur parce que je sais c'est
quoi
et pour l'entraîneur parce que j'ai vu
stéphan larouche haute est grand de le
faire grande
c'est une question que je devrais te
partir avec ton sportif dans
commandement pendant 12 mois 3mois de
rester le matin les seuls gymnase je
vous aimerai plus passer du temps avec
avec ma femme et je vais est-ce que vous
avez l'impression de vivre les belles
années de la boxe avec plus ou moins
bien là depuis quelques années
est ce que vous voulez c'est le sport en
meilleure santé j'espère j'espère que je
peux dire oui
puis si encore une fois content de ce
que j'ai fait payer pour les gens qui
est qui et qui va commencer à faire la
boxe jeu juste sous gestion de centaines
et comme il faut le talent après masse
le talent c'est en vain pour ça le reste
ce travail c'est mon opinion personnelle
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
talentueux mais si tu travailles pas si
tu es pas dédié à 100% ça va pas avoir
pas fonctionné mais le chat botté
félicitations pour votre grande carrière
de boxeur merci d'une voie en ce matin
merci beaucoup m